I I wanted to talk to you two about like
you and Bryan's experience in all this
because every time I've interviewed you
guys Brian Brian's a smart man he lets
you talk he's my amazing wife and she's
gonna talk so I'm wondering what it's
been like for him to kind of be on this
interracial relationship journey with
you to go right now in this moment and
protest with you because I haven't had a
chance to talk to him about that so I'll
ask for you to speak for him now what
what's it been like Ram yeah you know
something Brian shared with me the other
day that he's never said before and this
goes into the the show playing into
stereotypes every time Brian was on the
screen they played Latin music every
single time when he got out of the limo
and spoke to me in Spanish
I was already smitten Dulles was all
miss you got repeat after me okay they
told us some buddies came us me gusta
okay mas me go sir yes Brian s friend
whether he was when he came out of the
limo when he would come to approach me
when I was in Miami there was always
this music playing and Brian shared with
me that he never felt more Latin than he
did on the show I'm saying that to say
the show plays into stereotypes that
their audience has i that music they had
playing for Brian I never heard anything
like that before
in my you know relationship with Riley
its Bailey doesn't play that time you
know music it's just so playing into a
certain stereotype and people were not
receptive to our relationship at the end
of art at the end of the franchise so
we've always had to develop a thick skin
and figure out how we were going to
navigate this world is an interracial
couple and we did that from the very
beginning so for us going through what
the world is going through right now
we've had the tough discussions about
presenting herself as an interracial
couple before and you know how we want
to raise our children and Brian that has
always been like Godman
you know we our children will be half
black half Colombian we want them to
have experience both cultures and we'll
educate them on both
I'll be bilingual and they'll understand
understand their culture in its
Colombian and black protesting is
something that Brian hadn't done before
that I have and I it was important for
me that we did it together because we
are one unit were married and he was all
for it when I was explaining to him what
he'll feel when he protests what it
means to me and he got it and we've
always had like communications always
been the foundation of our relationship
and we always had those tough
conversations so watching Brian protest
and scream black lives matter and really
get emotional in the entire experience
of course I look over and I'm like gosh
I made the right decision because he
understands me and I understand him and
he just gets it but it was also about
marching for our future right our future
child who will be black I don't know if
it'll be a male or female but he may
face some of these in justices that
we're experiencing right now so we're
marching for our future family and
that's what was representative to me
when we went out there and did that that
day and now Brian's like so what are we
going again
[Music]